everybody messes up it's part of
business your employees are going to
mess up you're going to mess up as a
boss your customers are going to think
you messed up even when you didn't mess
up messing up happens and so if you act
every time like you have never had a
mess up before then you are going to
mess up even worse and so I'm going to
talk you about three different stories
about big mess ups that I have done and
been an experiencer of and some tactical
things that you can do that have made
our businesses so much better and turned
onear reviews into five star reviews and
the step-by process thinking through
that what do you do when you mess up
right cuz you're going to you're going
to mess up in business you're going to
mess up with a customer you're going to
you're going to BU build someone the
wrong amount you're going to give
someone the wrong date you're going to
forget to onboard someone you're going
to have a package that doesn't get
delivered it gets delivered to the wrong
address you're going to you're going to
onboard someone put the wrong company's
logo on it um and every one of those
examples that I just said is something
that we have done at some point in my
career and so I want to tell you two
stories um and then I to drive home a
couple of principles that have served us
well um use them if you want but they
have worked pretty well for us and so
I'll tell you two kind of polar extremes
so I I uh I buy a lot of gym equipment
um even though I'm not even in the gym
industry technically anymore um I have a
massive gym that is in our headquarters
that's really sweet I'll just put it
that way we've got like 85 unique pieces
in the gym and it's just just for me and
the team um and so I uh all the pieces
are bought from Individual people I kind
of put the pieces together that I like
and so it's not just one distributor and
so I had a piece of equipment that that
I bought and I was really excited about
it cuz I was like oh man I love this
piece it's going to be awesome and when
it showed up it was bent like the frame
was bent um and the and the weight stack
was kind of off and so one of the main
polls was bent so then it was like this
whole ordeal and when we called the
company up he was like well uh I mean
you you accepted the shipment and I was
like yeah cuz the truck guy was like
what do you want me to do this I was
like all right we'll drop it off he's
like well as soon as you accept the
shipment it's your liability and I don't
know if it like it happened before after
that and I was like well I'm telling you
it happened before and I just wanted to
help the guy out who was the truck
driver like complete his complete the
runs that you had for the day and he was
like sorry dude um and I was all right
well I mean can we can we get like the
pieces or something like a new frame
that you can ship out just that piece
and he's like well that's going to be
extra and I'm like dude I bought this
thing it arrived not the way that I
bought it
and now I'm incurring additional costs
in terms of financial cost but I also
have the additional cost of now I'm
talking to you when I'd rather be using
the piece of equipment and so the tldr
of that is I basically just threw the
piece out and I hate the person who I
did business with and I will tell
anybody who ever considers buying from
them that they suck now let's take the
alternative example so um last year I
went to uh Orlando for jimc con and we
stayed at uh the rits and when I went to
the rits we had our team with us and so
we went out they have a a Michelin star
restaurant there which by the way I
found out was actually named after
Michelin tires totally random I saw like
the Michelin tirean at the front of the
restaurant I was like this feels weird
but it's actually what it is anyways and
so we go in there and it's this this
really nice restaurant or whatever but
it took three and a half hours to eat
our entire meal we didn't get drinks for
like 45 minutes we didn't get the
appetizers until minute 990 and I was
like dude this is ABS I was like I
honestly just want to go get Chick-fil-A
like I don't even care right and so
anyways we finished the whole dining
experience if you want to call it that
and um the manager of the hotel you know
our team was like hey just letting you
know like this was pretty pretty tough
and as soon as the manager found out
about that he was so upset he was like
oh my God I can't believe this happened
we had just switched staff over we're
training some team up and I think we
were under you know short you know store
sa that day whatever and he said but
that's 100% our fault he said please let
me make it up to you and so for the
remainder of the trip like one he comped
the dinner that we had there which was
expensive uh then we got upgraded uh I
think rooms for the rest of our stay
they he said please like they delivered
like fruit baskets and drinks and other
stuff to our room throughout the day and
my teams room so it's not just me like
we had eight people with us staying in
four or five rooms um and so so all of
everybody got taken care of he made us
reservations at two different
restaurants the next basically every
other night for us to choose from and
then he met us at the restaurant to seat
us at the table he got us the appetizers
and drinks at the restaurants that he
met us at to make sure that we were okay
now I'll tell you this since then if I
go to Orlando I stay at the rits and I
talk and I talk to Javier because Javier
is my dude and Javier goes above and
beyond and the other guy at the other
company I don't say anything about now I
don't even want to say the name of the
company because I don't want to give
them air time all right and so I think
there's some really interesting
principles about this um that we've
taken from uh for our business so Disney
says that there's 37 magic moments that
it takes to make up for one tragic
moment and I think there's two kind of
levels to thinking about this so the
magic moments it means that it takes so
many good things to make up for one bad
thing so by all for all intents and
purposes avoid the tragic moment because
it's going to take you so many to make
up for it but if you do have that tragic
moment then you have to do a ton and I
see that on kind of bir directionally
now one of the things that um I like to
think about a lot is like I never want
to become someone's project and what I
mean by that is like if if you piss
someone off or you do something wrong
and you know you did something wrong you
don't you don't want that person to Stew
and just think like how am I going to
destroy this person like you don't want
to become someone's project and so I've
talked about the angry boat and I'm
going to get to that in a second but I
actually want to hit on this point
because I think it's really important
which is that a refund to a customer is
an apology but you have to do better
than that if you hit your wife and then
you apologize it's not just like oh
we're neutral it's just as if I hadn't
hit her it's like and I'm doing this as
a natural extremity hyperbolic but like
you wronging someone and saying I'm
sorry is not enough and so let me let me
prove the point if you accidentally kill
someone in manslaughter Society deems
you saying sorry family isn't enough so
what do what does the government do they
sentence you and they put you in prison
so they say you have to say sorry and
you have to pay 10 years because of
involuntary manslaughter they say sorry
isn't enough and so refunding someone
isn't enough if if Javier at the Ritz
had just refunded me the meal I wouldn't
be like stoked I would have been like
well you wasted 3 and 1 half hours of my
night and it's and like the food was
cult like all these other things like
I'm not like I'm not back to neutral
right like one tragic moment he gave me
a magic moment okay give me a refund and
so one of the things that you have to
wrap your head around and this took me
some time is like you actually are going
to go negative on refunds meaning like
you're going to lose money you're not
just going to be like oh well you paid
me 100 bucks I'm going to pay you $100
back now we're even it's no because
there's additional cost that they incur
and so like they got dressed up like or
like if we got dressed up to go out this
nice restaurant we have expectations of
the evening that are going to be really
good and so not only did we pay money
but we paid time and every person you
know the the the gals of my team got all
dled up and all that stuff and all of
this is for it goes completely into the
tragic perspective and so as a customer
or one of your customers has one of
these experiences it's like dude
refunding is them is not enough hey real
quick guys if you guys are enjoying this
don't be a square share I I'm going to
come up keep doing rhymes for this but
um if you can screenshot this right now
wherever you're listening and post it
and tag me I'm going to share as many of
these as I can on soci media and I will
certainly make more of them if you tell
me that you like them and so screenshot
share tag and I will see you in five
seconds and so we have to do have to go
above and beyond and so one of the
issues that happens though is that when
when it happens and this is this is now
me talking to the teammates so people
who work in businesses like what you
can't do and I'm just I'm just please
I'm begging you what you can't do is try
and minimize it to the customer right
like Javier could have been like
oh I mean like basically by saying
you're being ridiculous don't be a
victim like that's what the like that's
whatever you say when the person's like
hey the food was late the what all
you're doing is trying to invalidate
them you're basically saying you're
lying or you're not telling the truth or
I mean pick pick your poison and you're
basically saying that you don't matter
that's what you're saying and so what
happens is is that people then escalate
to be like yes I do matter and you don't
understand and not only that but I'm
gonna punish you and so what do you
think onear reviews are think about it
for a second a one-star review is a
customer's way of being the judicial
system and saying okay this person
refunded me but they needed to do more
and so I'm still going to jam them I'm
still going to put them in prison even
though they apologize for killing my
husband in manslaughter right even
though they apologize that wasn't enough
so I'm going to punish them with a
review because that's all I can do those
are the things that they have control
over and so we have to go above and
beyond and so I'll give you an example
recently and so we had a we had a
scheduling mishap um and we had seven
people who were going to fly out to our
headquarters and basically they came
here and there was nothing happening
that day because the sales team messed
up times and so it's like and and five
of these are international think about
this you you travel across the country
across the world to you get your
expectations up some people have to
apply for visas like big big big like
expectations big work big money all of
these things like beforehand right and
they show up and like nothing's
happening there was a scheduling mishap
right and so what do you do right like
that's a big big mess up that's a big
mess up it's absolutely
unacceptable so here's what you don't do
you don't say hey you should have
checked the email or hey we sent some
other correspondents that that might
have you know conf conflicted like you
don't go into any of that because it
doesn't matter they don't care what
matters is that it's always immediately
your fault and you have to be angrier
about it than they are and this is the
angry boat the thing is is that even
though I preach this it's still hard to
do when you're in the moment because no
one wants to accept fault because fault
is associated with all these negative
things in our past because in the
schooling system if you say your fault
you go to detention like you get
punished by saying it's your fault so
you always want to blame hey Timmy is
the one who who turned the music up not
me so Timmy gets punished but the
reality is that in business you always
always want it to be your fault because
if it's your fault it's under your
control which means you you have the
power to fix it that's what's key and so
as soon as you have that instance you
jump in the angry boat as fast as you
can you want to be quicker to the draw
at getting angry than the other person
and a lot of times customers will have
one of these experiences and they'll
shoot out the situation to wait to see
how you respond because they want to
they want you to be upset about this
because they are already angry and
they're trying to contain themselves
trying to contain their emotions and
what you need need to do is be the one
who gets emotional for them that is the
ultimate validation is that something
bad happens and you say that's
ridiculous that's unacceptable oh of
course we're going to give you your
money back of course I'm going to refund
all of your travel expenses which by the
way is what we did we give them their
money back give the travel expenses but
that's still not enough it's not enough
because if you traveled across the world
you're like okay well great my flights
but like I just lost 4 days of travel
and I had these expectations that
weren't met and so so we're taking the
whole the you know the seven people out
for 3 hours we're going to go to dinner
we'll I'll probably I'll probably end up
doing three hours of personalized
Consulting for each of these businesses
which is not something that I would
normally do um in an effort to go above
and beyond to make up for something that
that otherwise shouldn't have happened
and the reality is is this like let's be
let's put our let's put our hats on for
a second is this my fault Alex's fault
was I the one who took the call was I
the one who messed up the scheduling no
but guess whose fault it is it's mine
right I pay the people I'm the the buck
stocks with me and so the idea that
sometimes I see business owners saying
things like well that you know my team
messed dude you [__] messed up like
that's the thing about the
entrepreneurship game is like you get
you get the upside but you get the
downside you get it both and you've got
to be able to be comfortable with that
and the thing is is like you have to
accept and I want like this is the thing
as soon as I go in my mind is like I
flip this switch or it becomes a game of
how can I blow these people away all
right that as soon as I have like a
clear and obvious Rong and it happens we
mess things up we're human and humans
work for us and humans make mistakes and
so when as soon as as soon as that
happens it becomes this game of oh Ro Y
is out the window I'm already going to
lose money on this duh right like you're
going to give the money back plus extra
cost that they incurred plus now you're
still going to incur the cost that you
would have normally done to to do
deliver whatever it is that you do right
but the thing is is I am an [__]
advocate of the Ritz Carlton and Orlando
and Javier I tell everybody when they're
like hey where should I go I'm like go
there go to Javier he's the [__] man
and I tell everybody that and so I'll
bet you they have more than made up for
the transgression of the one restaurant
experience and him meeting me at the
other restaurants and sitting us down
and taking 5 minutes before two or three
or four other experiences we had while
we were there those little minutes meant
the world to me because I know what kind
of business owner what kind of
entrepreneur what kind of operator
operates that way it's somebody who gets
it you get the game which is that did
Javier mess up he's not even he's not
even responsible for the restaurant it's
not even his
division but he did it because he knows
that I don't
care and he had the power to fix it so
even if it wasn't his fault for the
transgression he had the power to fix it
and so it becomes his responsibility to
make it right and side note here with
the angry boat is one you want to
confront it headon you don't want to
[__] foot around it you got to say like
this was our mess up and I'm super
pissed about it second you want to get
in fast third validate validate validate
you want them to feel seen you want them
feel heard you want them to feel felt
you want them to feel felt you want them
to feel like you you you feel their pain
more than they feel their pain because
here's the here's the reality and this
is the this is the this is the underling
Highlight
point there is no way that you can
minimize someone's pain only they can
minimize it you cannot invalidate away
someone's feeling about being wronged
the only person who can say you know
what it's not a big deal is them and so
the only way for that to happen is for
you to be more upset so that they say
hey it's not that big of a deal calm
down and then they said it not you
because if you say hey it's not that big
of a deal calm down they're going to be
like r yes it is you need to validate me
and then you're like oh my God you're
right I should kill myself they're like
d don't kill yourself and you're like
right and they're like it's not that big
of it de like okay fantastic they come
back down and I say the I use I use
hyperbolic extremes to make a point
which is if you want someone to feel
better about something that you did that
wronged them they have to initiate it
and the only way they're initiate it is
if you make it a bigger deal to you than
it is to them and so I want to I want to
do a quick transition into um employee
stuff around this so if you were the
person who messed up like you're the
actual person now of course it's the
entrepreneur it's it's always our fault
for sure but on some level if you're the
person who messed up on the team let me
tell you what not to do don't try and
skirt along don't try and pretend like
it's not a big deal when you say to the
team don't try and minimize and be like
oh yeah I kind of messed up the the
dates on on that thing don't [__] do
that because it's the same thing in
reverse because the like the owner your
manager Your Leader the entrepreneur
he's the customer she's the customer in
this incident and I'll tell you what I
want to see I want to see you losing
your [__] mind over how upset you are
at this mess up because the thing is is
if you're not upset enough I'm going to
make you upset and so one of us is going
to make you upset and you want it to be
you not me being really real with you
and so what I I'll tell you what I I'll
tell you what I told um the individual I
said listen
I know because I know I know I know the
person you know like obviously multiple
parties blah blah blah but at some point
sometimes the buck can stop with
somebody I said listen I know that
you're beating yourself up over this and
you're beating yourself up over it in
silence I was like but the thing is is
like no one cares no one will give you
credit for beating yourself up in
silence they will give you credit for
two things making it right and making
sure it never happens again that's it
that's all that matters and so there is
there's no more useless
emotion than feeling sorry for yourself
it changes
nothing like no one gets better by
feeling sorry for themselves at all and
so if you did mess up just skip past the
guilt part skip past the shame part skip
past that and go immediately into the
what can I do to make it right what can
I do to make it better than right sure
you hit your wife sure you said sorry
but now what we got to take her out to
dinner get her a nice necklace get her
some flowers and then go to [__]
anger therapy and make sure that you
know like whatever like you you do all
the things to go from tragic to neutral
and then you go above neutral to try and
make them into a champion and then you
do all the things to make sure it
doesn't happen again that's the point
and so too many businesses basically
think that a refund is the highest level
of what they can do to make it right
they're like I gave him his money back
what else does he want a shitload more
that's what that's what they want way
more and the thing is is I'll tell you
this is that if you incur the cost of
the refund plus the additional cost is
then you lose actual money actual
resources trying to make it right guess
what you try not to do you try not to
[__] up so much in the future because
you know the real cost of it isn't just
like and like don't even get me started
on companies that won't give a REV like
go don't give a refund on something like
if people if if a a huge percentage of
your customers are asking for refunds
fix your [__] or stop selling it like
either you're selling it wrong and
you're setting crazy expectations that
no one no one can no one can live up to
or your just delivery sucks but like if
you're getting lots of re refund
requests and then you you're like well I
can't give the refunds otherwise I won't
be in business then maybe you shouldn't
be in
business fix your
[__] and I get I get I get I get I get
jazzed about this I like I came into the
team this morning I was like oh I know
what I'm G talk about because this is
hot because we just mess this up we just
had this mess up happen and like you
have to own it and you have refunds
Aren't Enough refunds are apologies no
one cares about apologies people want
more than an apology because they will
punish you and society believes that too
you don't just say I'm sorry I killed
somebody I'm sorry I was in a I was a
drunk driver and I killed your kid I'm s
sorry is not enough a refund is an
apology a refund is sorry and people
want more than that and so you got to
get them to neutral and then and here's
the cool part so this is my silver
lining for
this is that if you do turn a tragic
moment into a series of magic moments
afterwards you can create brand
Champions you have a higher potential to
take somebody and make them A True
Believer in what you do if when you mess
up you own it and you make it better
than right because they're like these
guys messed up but they went so far out
of their way and if anybody's ever had
this experience and I hope you have at
least one time in your life we a
business owner went above and beyond
they didn't just make it right they made
it better than right and then what
happens you become a customer for life
you have a higher potential for being a
customer for life and I remember there
was a um an acquaintance of mine who was
in the hot sauce business just kind of
random and he had a c so he had um he
had sent them a hot sauce kit or
something and it didn't have caps and so
he couldn't they couldn't use the hot
sauce because it didn't have a cap in
the kit and so he sent a handwritten
note to them and he sent extra caps uh
not just enough but like more of them
just in case or whatever and
they said um they they sent him back a
note being like wow that was so nice of
you like you went above and beyond
whatever and so he actually started
sending the kits with handwritten notes
with an extra cap because of that
experience because that person then went
change their one star to a five star
because of the great experience and I
don't know if you've ever done this or
you've seen this like updated reviews
where people say hey I left this one
star the the founder reached out to me
he got on the phone with me he made it
right the thing is is that people want
to punish you when they feel invalidated
and you can absolutely you can you can
make them feel validated like the reason
malpractice so they did a bunch of
research like because both my parents
are
Physicians um there's a ton of ton of
research on malpractice the people who
get sued for malpractice are doctors
that people hate not people who make the
most mistakes isn't that interesting so
they tell this story of a lady who uh
had some sort of thing that happened
that was wrong in like a clear lawsuit
and she had had like two or three
Physicians that she was going for like
cancer or something whatever it was and
when the uh she hired this male practice
Journey because she wanted to go after
this physician and so after doing more
research the lawyer was like hey it's
not this guy who actually technically
made the mess up it's this one your
primary care you're your general
physician and the lady was like oh Sarah
oh I love Sarah no it's it's fine and so
it had nothing to do with the
transgression it had to do with the fact
that they actually hated the person and
so the thing is is like people people
people want to punish you if they don't
like you and you you increase the
likelihood that they do like you by
going above and beyond and so here's one
tactical thing one more last tactical
thing uh from my notes that I'll give
you if you deal in a business that has
lots of transactions high volume
transactions every day what you want to
do is you want to give someone a box of
responsibility you want to give a box of
decision-making power and so they do
this in in the hotel industry and this
is why I like stealing things from one
industry and putting to another and so
for example if someone wakes up in the
middle of the night because they smell
smoke right and they come they call to
the front desk they say hey I Smell
Smoke I can't sleep blah blah blah that
front desk person if they have no power
to fix it the customer still holds them
responsible so they basically you give
them a losing card they can't do
anything but if you say these are the
things that you have within your
responsib that within your power you can
give someone free free drink credits you
can give someone a free meal you can
give someone a free upgrade all right so
these are the three things you can do
based on the level of the the mess up
right if if someone had to wait 20
minutes for a bell hop okay is that like
end of the world probably not here's
here's two drinks uh just in case you're
waiting or for tonight to make it
special before you go out all right now
if someone can't sleep because there's
smoke and they shouldn't have had smoke
in the that's a pretty big mess up so
what do we do well if the front desk
person has the power to upgrade them for
the next room for the next night then
you probably refund them for the night
before and give them a free upgrade for
the next
night but you have to give people you
have to give your team the two or three
things that they can do and then just
say listen if we're if you're using up
more than five of these a month then
like we need to fix a process here but
these are things that you can give out
as freebies that you bake into the
profit margins of the business so that
you know that you can make things right
when things do inevitably grow wrong
because people are human and humans
dealing with humans leads to mistakes so
um what to do when you mess up is don't
just refund someone that is not enough
go above and beyond and if you do that
you might just turn a hater into a
lifelong
fan be awesome take care of your
customers all that good stuff oh by the
way share this if you can uh mean a lot
to me and all that stuff otherwise I
otherwise I'll stop doing these not
really I won't stop doing them but it
would just mean a lot more um if you did
that because then I'll know that you do
like it and then I will actually I will
I will probably make more if you share
it how about that rather than stop or
start I will probably make more if you
share it these um anyways keeping
awesome catch you soon bye